today i am really pleased to have with
me stu j ray who is a person that uh in
the polyglot to sphere
somebody that i've been following for it
must be it's certainly more than 10
years i don't know how many years
and i've seen him
and he excels in
languages that i don't know anything
about like southeast asian languages of
asian languages so without further ado
stu
can you tell us a little about what you
do where you live
and what your various uh you know
activities are on the internet
so thank you steve it's an honor to um
to be here with you and a long time
coming uh first of all my name so stu j
raj
that's the indian
right yes um but that's cool you can
call me what you want um i
most people in this part of the world
know me as my middle name jay it's a lot
easier in thai and it actually flows
well in thai the other thing is stewart
sounds like satyawat
which sounds like cockroach which is
also a pimp in thai so my name in this
part of the world everyone knows me as
jay everyone else stew and very few is
raj and my chinese name wang huay lila
so okay depends what you want to call so
um yeah
i've been here in uh my base is thailand
here for over 20 years now before that
indonesia originally from australia
uh i grew up speaking a bunch of
languages my grandfather was a polyglot
he spoke my so my white grandfather on
my mom's side
um he spoke
chinese japanese hebrew russian
french italian
latin and a bunch of other languages and
so as a kid we grew up
playing with language and sound and
morse code and listening to shortwave
radios
and it just grew from there and so as i
grew up i also had a surrogate family
was indonesian so i grew up speaking
indonesian and then chinese they were
chinese indonesians so from my
grandfather both chinese and then the
indonesian side they also speak chinese
and
it grew up our base language at home
here is thai
and then
around in my work basically i work with
companies
around the world governments in
aerospace oil and gas modern trade a
bunch of different industries where
language is just a tool to get other
things done so it's building
communication channels making deals and
for me language is
a thing that gives me an edge especially
in this region and with this looking
face
um you're able to speak with western
clients as one of them but then also
speak with people on the ground and get
them to open up as one of them
and so that's where that's where i'm
from i guess the languages that i use
the most are thai indonesian mandarin
actually surprisingly danish
spanish
and then other languages from around the
region yeah i thought danish was an
asian language actually yeah actually it
is you'd be surprised how many
scandinavians just listen to it
no just to listen to it yeah stoop
yeah
so and you do you have like a youtube
channel or a blog or anything of that
nature yes so actually if you go to um
anything stu jay so mind cr so my blog
if you do a youtube search on stu jay
stuart j so gj you find me um otherwise
go to mindcraft that's with a k so
m-i-n-d-k-r-a-f-t
dot me and i've been migrating
everything into that because this is the
latest project that i've done
um from this year which will hopefully
keep growing out which is consolidating
everything from language from tech and
just the brain and learning and we have
a huge community there so minecraft.me
is like the portal into that jcademy is
my learning
um platform j-c-a-d-e-m-y.com
[Music]
but they they sort of host the content
of minecraft and other stuff and then we
have a great discord server but it's all
minecraft of me would be a first port of
call
so we'll leave that information with
links in the description box
now first question is
which languages in fact do you speak
um
as as you know there's a big gradient
the languages that i speak regularly and
that i
let's start with the languages that i
facilitate
training and do work in
and do business in regularly
uh indonesia and malay of course thai
lao and and anything i guess from these
thai
gradient of languages
um
chinese so mandarin uh cantonese
uh to when i'm in hong kong i'll use
cantonese uh quite a bit but my mandarin
is much more strong stronger than my
cantonese um then we go down to like
vietnamese burmese we're talking about
this part of the world vietnamese
burmese i will use them
um
when i need to go down and speak to
people and get things done however say
my vietnamese and burmese wouldn't be at
the level where i'd facilitate full
classes yet
possibly soon but not yet
then i also actually use spanish a lot i
during my
university years
i shifted my italian which my
grandfather used to speak with me
into spanish and
i also played jazz so i played with a
bunch of latino musicians as well for
many years in university and dated a
chilean woman
for four years so they got my spanish up
to par
um
danish of course and and swedish and
norwegian i'll put those in there when
i'm in sweden and norway
why the scandinavian language at school
there was surprisingly a big community
of
exchange students both of my friends who
would go and live in scandinavian
countries and scandinavian students that
came
and
went to our school and so there were a
bunch of us that just spoke scandinavian
languages together and so i got the bug
and so as a young kid i actually then
took it off my bat to go in and i think
i've told this story in other places but
basically i looked up scandinavian
surnames in the then white pages and
yellow pages for scandinavian
restaurants i tracked out where in
sydney they were and i went door
knocking
and i found a scandinavian community and
it just happened that danish was the
predominant one there where i found and
i really just immersed myself in danish
and ended up in book clubs and
everything as a young kid um to the
point that i actually got quite fluent
back then uh into my teenager and with
danish
you know if anybody wants to get a
danish experience they should look up
at the seaside hotel in netflix
oh really the series it's phenomenal
phenomenal all in danish it's a lovely
it's a lot very a lot of fun just a lot
of fun
hotel i think i put in the beach hotel i
can't remember what it's called but
something like that i think i put a clip
out recently where i spoke danish but if
i were to do it all again knowing what i
know now and having traveled through
also norway and sweden i think i would
have learned norwegian first um because
danish has had a long lasting impression
on my throat which is really hard to
kick when you're speaking swedish and
norwegian
okay interesting so
if one question comes to mind like
people have stereotypes
uh you know
the it's not unusual to see an asian
looking person speak uh aussie english
with an aussie accent or uh you know
american english or even scottish
whatever you know that's just a given
but when you see someone who doesn't
look thai
or laotian or uh you know vietnamese
even chinese
like
what do you think is more difficult for
a say a european language native speaker
to learn those
languages that seem exotic to us or is
it easier for those people to learn what
is probably to them a more exotic
language english or french or spanish
which way is it easier
i think it's expected in the west that
anyone going there will learn the
language if they're living in the
country over here you get
what's called these expat bubbles i
guess and which you know what's the
difference between ex-pattern and
immigrant
but these expat bubbles
where
people live
20 30 years without having to speak uh a
word of the local language so this
becomes annoying
um
what i have found however and since day
one because i knew a lot of languages
that feed into thai as well as like old
chinese middle chinese and then from my
dad's side so hindi and sanskrit
and and other indic languages thai was
actually quite easy um to get up to
speed i could you know write it in an
afternoon from my understanding of dev
nagari
and sanskrit and so
within months i was up speaking thai
and the thing that i find is
it's not difficult but you just have to
get beyond that but it's understanding
this system um and it is that system
that's based on and even chinese is
based on it i don't know if you've ever
looked at their cheyenne system in
chinese but this is also based on the
map of the human mouth which is the
devanagari or sanskrit
brahmic
map
and so everything from tones your ping
uh
rule tones in mandarin are paralleled
one to one in these boxes that you have
tie tones and vietnamese and anything
um is actually based on this map which
is traced back to sanskrit believe it or
not even the korean writing is based on
this same format from sanskrit so
having that it's not a hard jump but if
you're going into thai say as your first
asian language and not having that
background
it is like what the heck is this because
most native speakers of thai don't
actually understand the system because
they're native speakers nobody ever
taught them right and even in the
schools and so the way they learn is by
rote and just by memorizing rules that
seemingly don't make sense so that is a
huge challenge but actually thai is not
a difficult language to
to learn
and to develop porosity in and this is
the key i think is developing this
procedure
and porosity always trumps what you look
like on the outside if i go into a
7-eleven
and i can speak in a way that feels
natural
um
they'll instantly just speak to me
normally
and there are some tricks that you can
throw some cues in
um that will uh for example if you go in
um
you don't need to put that in a plastic
bag and the way that i say that is a
colloquial way that anyone else would
say it and they might even be looking at
your face and then the whole interaction
will just be in thai and go without any
surprise at all
why there there is a tendency for them
to speak to you in english as soon as
they look at you yeah so this gets back
to you then your question the big
challenge is and most people say oh they
just won't speak thai to me
um or they just won't speak chinese to
me maybe you've had that where people
just speak english to you
um and so that is one of the biggest
challenges i found that to be a function
of how well you speak the language i
never get that in chinese i never get it
in japanese i shouldn't say never but
very rarely yeah i agree um
you know if the person assumes that you
speak their language better than they
speak your language they'll happily most
people are happy to use the language
that makes the most sense let me ask you
a question what advice now so a lot of
those languages are tonal yep
uh so someone who wants to learn a tonal
language whether it be mandarin or
cantonese or
you know thai or whatever
burmese is
tonal as well isn't it
yeah so and and presumably they're not
going to learn the sanskrit uh rules or
whatever it was
uh
what sort of general bits of advice do
you have for people okay so presumably
you just said they're not going to learn
the sanskrit rules um
that's why i've set minecraft up
actually
you're insane not to learn the sanskrit
rules
okay um because and this is the other
thing tones in english we think of tones
the word tone has a connotation with
pitch
tones are not pitch
and i'll say that again tones are not
pitched tones are throat positions
and the pitch is a byproduct of the
throat so you and you get these people
learning tonal languages and they'll
even get these graphs and try and plot
the frequencies of their their actual
pitch to match native speakers and they
still get the tone wrong they still get
the confused looks on the face and it's
especially apparent in vietnamese
because tones are a whole
bunch of different things that are going
on in the throat which are actually
traced back to that sanskrit map it's
not a difficult map you've got
asperger's was sanskrit eternal language
um no it's it wasn't well you actually
had pictures so similar to pitch accent
however that it's this is the whole
thing because tones are not pictures in
english we use this stupid word tone
which forces everybody to focus on
something to do with pitch and it's not
you focus on the throat and so if i say
like i've got normal voice
you see the voice is just
and it glides off and then i've got
stiff voice
my
my voice cuts it and then i've got
creaky voice ma
where it ratchets down at the end they
are the only three tones originally in
any tonal language whether it's burmese
whether it's chinese whether it's
vietnamese whether it's thai tai
languages
and then
you've got registers so you've got
breathy voice so aspirate so
you've got um voices that where the
glottis is closed in the beginning
and then you've got voiced
and so between these three
and then those um
different um
what i what i just mentioned then about
the the stiff voice normal voice and the
creaky voice that makes a matrix of nine
and then you have
um whether it's dead at the end so ma
versus
ma
that tkp at the end will kill it and so
you've got short and long vowels then
with those and so you have a three by
five grid and this three by five grid
maps to every single tonal language in
the region
vietnamese chinese cantonese hokkien
thai every thai dialect these are called
gedny boxes google get me boxes
g-e-d-n-e-y
and so
these gedny boxes are based on what's
going on in the mouth and the pitch then
is just a byproduct but you don't have
to get the actual pitch contours exact
because actually the pictures change
depending what's around them
but getting the throat right so you
would know in chinese if you've got two
number three tones
so number three tone is learnt as how by
learners of of chinese and so they will
try and pronounce that how perfectly
every time they see a number three tone
but it's not
so the the
the the throat is actually closing up
and pulling it up which is where the
rising tone originally came from the
was the throat closing with a glottal
stop at the end and ha
is because you're getting this god will
stop not having to finish all the way
because it's at that bottom arc of the
third tone
and so
chinese learners will go in and learn
all of these rules how these all clip
together but if you just memorize this
grid and memor and get the throat
actions correct you'll find that all of
this tone sandy and all of these rules
based around tones actually just come
out in the wash
and you'll sound very natural and so
this is what i i do i actually teach
people whether they're learning sanskrit
or not how to actually read the map
because and and then if you read chinese
you'll understand the che yoon system
which is based on the sanskrit system
the ghetto boxes are based on the
sanskrit system and believe it or not
even
um
non-tonal languages like khmer
but khmer
changes the vowels based on these same
categories and so
if you looked at it then well it's only
the pitch that's not being affected but
the vowel just like it is in vietnamese
or tie
affects the overall consonant with with
the with the initial consonant so
i would say don't focus too much on
pitch
focus on the mechanics of what's going
on in your throat get that right and
then the tones will start to come out in
the wash just get yourself exposed to a
lot of the natural language
well i you know this is all new to me
i'll have to look it up i know nothing
about it i tend to just
listen and wing it well you know you
know what else is cool like in my
minecraft class this past week we're
also looking at russian and scandinavian
languages and the
uh
i'm just learning russian now but the
interslavic
but you will find that even the and so
there
for russians listening to sanskrit
russian is almost just like listening to
a dialect of sunscreen
i can share some resources with you and
the spelling rules of russian so you've
got your um
and your savory snacks so the the hard
marker and the soft uh the soft marker
they map
exactly to where these tones are and the
first two rows of the sanskrit graph so
you don't have to remember individual
letters all you have to remember is any
sound
that comes from the back of the throat
or the palette in this sanskrit map
you would never use a soft consonant
with it that will always come out as
their name their natural thing and they
map directly to the sanskrit grid
so learning this five by five grid which
is a map of the mouth
back of the throat cha-cha-cha-chan yeah
palette
top of the mouth
lips
going from back to front and then you've
got unvoiced aspirated voiced voiced
aspirated nasal
that's a 5x5 grid and it works across
all tonal languages and believe it or
not even the spelling rules of russian
and other slavic languages
wow
very interesting very interesting and so
you know i was in vietnam briefly i
tried to learn a bit before i went but
didn't get me very far
uh
had no it's no success with with burmese
but i wasn't there very long either
uh i guess of tonal languages i just
speak mandarin and cantonese
and
[Applause]
i you know i found with the mandarin
what helped me the most was listening to
xiangsha
because the xiang xiang performers
exaggerate and the whole thing about
tones to me was getting into the sort of
you talked about prosody or into the
rhythm of of a phrase or a sentence and
if you can somehow pick up on that
then uh your tones will fall into place
i don't know any of the rules but i i
did certainly
imagine was the first tonal language i
learned so i tried to remember which
word was which tone which character was
which tone but when when i went into
cantonese i didn't bother with that at
all i just i just listened to it someone
said that there's nine tones in ken you
know the theory they can't like all
asian no i shouldn't say all but a lot
of people speakers of asian languages
like to and not just asian languages
people like to pretend that their own
language is the most difficult language
in the world
so and any you know polls say their
language is the most difficult like
everybody believes their language is the
most difficult
and and the cantonese oh nine tones is
so much more difficult than mandarin
and then i read a book that said
actually with six stones you'll do just
fine and that is what persuaded me to
learn cantonese because that nine tones
looked like too much work but six tones
is only two more than four okay so this
is this is other advice that you say um
learning tonal languages
yeah stop counting tones
just like okay stop counting tones they
there are the same amount of tones
in every tonal language there's not the
same amount of his
language yeah no no no but i'm talking
about tones so yeah
but not pit but the pictures might
coincide
so in cantonese where is cha in in
mandarin you've got mama ma this
number one tone is actually ping that's
so it's your ping and ma
is also a
ping but you had yin and yang that yin
and yang was what i just mentioned the
voiced and unvoiced
so so what cantonese is closer to the
old chinese where it just splits so
you've got two registers originally you
had a high register and a low register
so you've got ma
[Music]
and then you've got
ma
ma
so you've just got a high register and a
low register and then
and and those other three ones so six to
nine is basically they are different
tones if you're counting actual tone
categories but what it means is
that they're dead so or they're they're
stopped at the end so
and ma
would be counted as two different tones
traditionally if you're counting natural
tones
if i say something in cantonese and my
wife is a native speaker of cantonese
yep
if i say something in context it comes
out not too bad
yeah if i say two words i get them all
wrong and she laughs at me so so as long
as i can get them they send somehow
whatever then okay that's okay but if i
had to hit you know hey what hi hi i
don't know
how
but if i get it in a sentence
it all hangs together and even if it's
off a little bit it's part of that
larger hole yeah and so the tones come
off okay so people think oh gee nick on
the ko
you know which isn't true and i can be
better sometimes than other times but if
you try to isolate them i'll get it
wrong the the thing is too and it's all
what you're using the language for
there are num languages say like chinese
too if you go to china it's just
expected now that people speak chinese
even if you've got a foreign face it's
just expected
there are other countries where it's not
expected and there are other countries
um
where there's very
little leniency done for non-standard
version of their language okay right so
vietnamese is an example of that
thai is an example of that so even thais
even if they speak their dialect from
up north east or the north or south or
wherever
um when they come to bangkok
they will force themselves to speak
central thai and if they
don't there's almost shame to it
and so
i guess it's this nationalistic thing
too but
everybody must speak this standard tie
and so that rule is then also applied to
foreigners
so if it's just a little bit off in
thailand
thais will not understand learning
but listen you know what i'm going to
stop it there i think it's been
fascinating because i know so little
about those languages and i certainly
haven't gone at it in the sort of
systematic way that you have and i think
many of my viewers will be very
interested in following up whether it be
minecraft or the other uh you know links
that we will leave in the description
box
and i'm sure we could go on talking for
a long time on this it is quite
interesting i am going to look into it
because it's it's quite fascinating and
and it's a big part of the world and
we're talking well
china of course 1.5 billion people but
southeast asia indonesia south asia
we're talking about half the world yeah
so well worth all of us learning more
about so
thank you very much it's been very
interesting and i'm going to follow up
okay okay bye-bye thank you